on this thursday night ontario's billion
dollar boost to test and trace covid19
the promise of more tests plus new rules
on who can get one
the health experts are telling us that
we need to be more strategic
with testing and the pressure to tighten
restrictions again
off the serve and on to other benefits
how much money canadians can expect and
the politics
over the payments we can't stress the
urgency of getting this bill through
the staggering toll of canada's opioid
crisis
recovery is not the same for everyone
two provinces two different responses
and should we cancel thanksgiving we'll
work around we're trying to be
coveted safe how to make plans with
pandemic protocols
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we heard from the prime minister
yesterday the second wave has already
started in parts of this country
and we've reported for weeks on how
daily case numbers are on the rise
now hospitals too are starting to fill
up with patients who are seriously ill
with covid19
let's start first with the daily case
counts quebec is reporting almost 600
new cases today for the second time in a
week
in ontario 409 more people tested
positive
out west there are 158 new cases in
alberta and 148
in bc and though hospitalizations are
nowhere near where they were in the
spring
over the last few weeks in bc alberta
ontario and quebec numbers
have started to rise in quebec today 184
people with kobit 19 are in the hospital
that's nearly doubled since the start of
the month in ontario the number of
patients in hospital doubled from 44 to
88
in the span of one week hospitals are
now sounding the alarm
and in ontario where there are long
lineups for covid19 tests the government
is scrambling to meet the demand
despite knowing a second wave was likely
in the fall
premier doug ford promised today to
invest 1 billion dollars to expand
testing and contact tracing
ford used to say everyone who wants a
test should get a test
now that's changing eric sorenson
explains the new criteria
and how it's led to more confusion
the long lineups a sober symbol of the
state of covet 19.
the virus is making a comeback and
canada's biggest province has been
caught without
sufficient testing capacity we were at
st mike's yesterday
and we waited for three hours and the
lineup didn't move whatsoever
ontario has now pledged to put a billion
dollars into testing and contact tracing
but first an urgent new protocol no
longer suggesting
anyone get tested anytime we know that
over the summer when we opened up
testing to anybody who wanted it
we did not find cases so
right now we need to focus on people who
are
symptomatic current assessment centers
will now be for those who have symptoms
or have had contact with non-coveted
cases or where outbreaks have occurred
new testing centers initially at more
than 50 ontario pharmacies
will start friday and by appointment for
people with no
symptoms but who are workers visitors or
others in high-risk settings such as
long-term care facilities
and people with no symptoms and no clear
risk factors
should not be going for tests at all
infectious disease experts say the
system wasn't prepared for a covet
resurgence
when we opened up the floodgates that
everybody come and get tested for
whatever reason but as soon as that
surge came we had no
give and then you start seeing all these
lineups
places people can't get tests the
province plans to expand testing and is
looking at other options such as saliva
tests now being used in bc
but as the number of coven 19 cases
rises sharply
more than three dozen doctors have
issued a call to reimpose restrictions
on non-essential businesses nightclubs
restaurants
gyms even places of worship we really
need to protect everyone around us
by stopping these types of socializing
congregate settings
that is not something the ontario
government is prepared to do
yet we're doing all these measures to
make sure we can keep the economy moving
moving forward we are not that point
right now but again everything's on
on the table unfortunately it is pretty
difficult
to normalize your economy without first
tackling covet 19. a second wave was
always anticipated but it has surged
quickly
and autumn has barely begun eric
sorensen global news
toronto the quebec government has
released a scathing report on a private
long-term care home where dozens of
people died from covet 19.
an investigation into residence herron
found the owners displayed
organizational
negligence 38 people died at the home
between march 26 and april 16th
most staff had abandoned the facility
after the first
covit 19 case when health authorities
arrived in late march
they found just three employees caring
for 133 residents
the investigation concludes authorities
at the care home repeatedly failed to
address shortcomings
because of high staff turnover and a
lack of personnel
millions of canadians who lost their
jobs or were unable to work because of
the pandemic are still depending on the
serb
the federal emergency response benefit
pays 500
a week and it's been extended a few
times but it comes to an
end this weekend there is a plan to
replace it and transition people
off it david aiken explains what it
means for you and how politics will
determine how it all plays out
a new session of parliament and some new
plans to help the 4 million canadians
on the serb after that program ends
most of those nearly three million
people will move to a
simplified employment insurance program
that will see recipients receive a
minimum
of five hundred dollars a week that's
the same as the serb
while they look for work the government
originally had set that minimum payment
at
four hundred dollars a week but boosted
it to match the serb
after pressure from ndp leader jug meat
singh the help that goes to families
that
are going to see their serb ending in a
couple days
that that amount of support does not get
cut by 400 which is what the liberals
were proposing
we fought and won for people but more
than a million serb recipients will not
qualify for that new ei program and for
those
a trio of new recovery benefit programs
one for the self-employed one for those
who need short-term paid sick leave
and one for caregivers those programs
too
will pay five hundred dollars a week now
the new ei
program is already in place those
changes
only required cabinet approval but the
other
recovery benefit programs requires
approval
by the house of commons and that's where
politics and a minority government come
into play
we can't stress the urgency of getting
this bill through
i've worked very collaboratively with my
critics i know our house leaders working
with other house leaders
now the government does have a few
options to quickly pass the bill through
the house of commons but
it has not said how or if it will use
those options
and so it looks like it could be an
uncertain week for the
million or so canadians who after next
week
can no longer depend on the serb donna
david the throne speech was yesterday
there has to be a confidence vote on it
at some point and the fate of the
liberal minority government rests on
that
what reaction is it getting
well not unsurprisingly it's been a bit
mixed i mean progressive groups they
like the ambition of national child care
national
pharmacare new targets on climate change
things like that
but in the house of commons the
opposition was not impressed
mr speaker yesterday's liberal throne
speech simply repeated
the failed promises they've already
failed to keep mr speaker yesterday
once again the liberals repeated their
promise
of national pharmacare they claim
they're paving the way
to universal pharmacare for canadians
but they refuse
to commit to public delivery and fail to
set out any timeline for action
and the premiers of quebec ontario
manitoba and alberta they didn't like
the speech from the throne
they say it tramples on provincial
jurisdictions
here's what alberta premier jason
kennedy had to say that
throne speech was filled with as i say
endless distractions and bright shiny
objects
and was not focused on the central
imperative
that should unite leaders across
partisan and geographic lines
which is protecting lives and
livelihoods
as for that confidence vote in the house
of commons still not decided when that's
going to happen
mps will be debating the speech from the
throne at least until october the 6th
donna all right david aiken in ottawa
thanks
there is another public health emergency
that is killing more canadians
right now than covid19 but it's been
overshadowed by the pandemic
there's been a huge increase in opioid
overdoses in bc and alberta in recent
months
and as heather urex west explains the
provinces have different ideas on how
the crisis
should be handled the tierney family has
seen
the devastation of canada's opioid
crisis up close
we now know eight different families
that have lost
a child to this epidemic
compared to covid19 canada's other
health crisis has proven
to be far more deadly in bc alone there
have been 1068 overdose deaths between
january and
august of this year alberta has seen 449
deaths between january and june
that's more than triple the number of
people who have died of coven 19
in those two provinces combined we're
certainly seeing
more toxic fentanyl on this on the
streets the higher concentrations
are being found in postmortem sampling
it's why
bc has worked at expanding access to a
safe drug supply
emphasizing a continuum of services from
supervised consumption sites
to addiction recovery programs as long
as i'm able to get there every day
it completely changes my life
keegan tierney has been enrolled in an
injectable opioid agonist therapy
program in calgary for more than a year
it gives him a controlled dose of a
prescribed opioid each day
but next spring that program and another
one in edmonton
will lose provincial funding we've also
seen you know a move away from funding
harm reduction services which we know
are very effective for preventing
overdose deaths
we've seen cuts to treatment that's
effective for opioid use disorders
albertans know that facilitating
addiction
as the federal government now wants to
do by handing out free narcotics to
addicts
is not compassion and that's why our
focus is on
treatment and recovery alberta's
government says it's in the process of
creating 4
000 new publicly funded treatment spaces
but for the tyranny family
that's not good enough recovery is not
the same for everyone
this has been a life saver for keegan
for our family and we are fighting for
it
with lives like keegan's at stake
heather urex west global news
calgary 40 days until america votes
coming up the alarming thing president
trump said he might do
if he loses
authorities are pleading for calm so
there's not another night like this in
louisville kentucky violence broke out
last night as protesters took to the
streets to demand
justice for briana taylor two officers
are recovering after being shot in a
scuffle with the demonstrators
one man has been arrested and is facing
charges on wednesday a kentucky grand
jury decided not to charge any officers
directly for taylor's death
in march police burst into her home as
part of a botched drug
investigation no drugs were found and
the 26 year old was shot and killed by
the police
demonstrators are planning to be out
again tonight
in washington d.c what should have been
a solemn moment on the steps of the
supreme court
turned into boos and chants against the
u.s president
people shouted vote him out as president
trump and the first lady paid their
respects to the flag-draped coffin of
former supreme court justice ruth bader
ginsburg
who died last week ginsburg's
granddaughter said her dying wish was
not to be replaced until after the
november presidential election
but trump is pushing ahead he's expected
to name his nominee on saturday
and senior republicans are insisting
tonight there will be a peaceful
transition of power should president
trump lose that election
they're doing that because trump said
something alarming yesterday when a
reporter asked him directly
if he will commit to a smooth transition
of power this
was his answer well we're going to have
to see what happens you know that i've
been complaining very strongly about
the ballots and the ballots are a
disaster and
that but people are rioting do you
commit to making sure that there's a
peaceful transfer
we want to have get rid of the ballots
and you'll have a very trans we'll have
a very peaceful
there won't be a transfer frankly
there'll be a continuation
a continuation the answer should have
been a simple yes
it's enshrined in the u.s constitution
that whoever loses must relinquish the
presidency
trump says all kinds of wild things but
as jackson proskow reports
this is something that shouldn't be
ignored
never has a u.s president shown such
open disregard for an election
we're going to have to see what happens
40 days before the vote and donald trump
has mounted a full out assault
claiming it will be impossible for him
to lose legitimately
it's a rigged election it's the only way
we're going to lose refusing to commit
to a peaceful transfer of power if he's
voted out
get rid of the ballots and you'll have a
very trans we'll have a very peaceful
there won't be a transfer frankly there
will be a continuation
what country are we in look uh
he says the most irrational things
historians see something much more
alarming
the language of authoritarianism all of
this
is meant to again this
discount of confidence to destroy
confidence that our systems can work
the use of mail-in ballots during the
pandemic has only increased the odds of
a disputed election
lawyers for both republicans and
democrats are already duking it out over
which votes should count
amidst warnings there may not be a
result for weeks
if the election is close there might be
a low period in which we don't know who
wins and
you know i think it's reasonable to be
concerned about what that what might
happen in that sort of period
trump seems to be preparing for chaos
claiming this election will be decided
by the courts
not the voters it's a scam the scam will
be before the united states supreme
court
the president is rushing to fill the
vacancy left by the late justice ruth
bader ginsburg
should he need it for that fight trump
is
aiming to do what his contemporaries in
turkey and russia now do
which is to use the institutions of
democracy
to maintain themselves in power but
trump's claims of voter fraud have
consistently been proven
false four years ago he claimed that the
election he won
was rigged without providing any
evidence on thursday the fbi director
testified that there is no evidence of
any coordinated voter fraud campaign
by mail or any other means jackson
prosko global news washington
nearly 500 retired u.s generals admirals
and national security officials now
openly say trump is not equal to the
challenges of being commander-in-chief
they are publicly endorsing joe biden
for the presidency
in an open letter they say the current
president has demonstrated he is not
equal to the enormous responsibilities
of his office
he cannot rise to meet challenges large
or small
the lengthy list of signatories includes
22 retired four-star military officers
top brass from every branch of the u.s
military some of who
served under president trump the letter
goes on to say joe biden has the
character principles wisdom and
leadership
necessary to address a world on fire
still ahead police in vietnam raid a
recycling operation
that might make you turn green
canada the uk and the u.s are set to
impose sanctions on the man who claims
he is the president of belarus plus
several other people the allies say
authoritarian leader alexander
lukashenko is not the country's
legitimate leader
and they condemn his secret inauguration
on wednesday canada says it shows his
disregard for basic democratic
principles
and the fundamental human rights of the
people of belarus
government forces have detained or
driven out the country's leading
opposition figures
and arrested thousands of peaceful
protesters
hong kong police have arrested joshua
wong a prominent
pro-democracy activist wong says the
arrest related to participating in an
unauthorized assembly in october 2019
and violating a pre-pandemic law banning
the wearing of masks
in public places wong was a key figure
in last year's pro-democracy protests in
hong kong
that prompted beijing to impose a
sweeping national security law
that law is largely seen as undemocratic
and severely restricts
political speech and police in vietnam
raided a warehouse that was recycling
something that
really shouldn't be recycled dozens of
large bags were found containing more
than 300 thousand
used condoms a woman told police they
were
boiled in water and then dried and
reshaped before they were
repackaged and sold the owner of the
warehouse said they received a monthly
input of
used condoms from an unknown source
next changing tradition how to carve up
a safe
thanksgiving
you're watching global national
how's this for a dramatic high angle
rescue two window washers in toronto
were saved near the 25th floor of a high
rise after their platform gave way and
crashed to the ground the men had safety
harnesses on they dangled briefly before
scrambling onto a narrow ledge
firefighters broke windows in the
building and managed to pull them to
safety
neither they nor anyone on the ground
were injured
well six months into this pandemic we
are approaching another holiday and the
prospect of not being able to gather to
celebrate it
when the prime minister said yesterday
we likely won't be gathering for
thanksgiving he did say
we still have a shot at christmas let's
hope so
but as abigail beeman explains it's
probably wise to prepare to adjust
lots of our traditions
[Music]
potatoes probably just seasoned meat in
general
the wissman family is not letting covet
19 cancel thanksgiving
life goes on we as a family get together
we had little have to
work around the limitations my fellow
canadians in his address to the nation
the prime minister took a hard line on
holidays it's all too likely we won't be
gathering for thanksgiving
but we still have a shot at christmas a
message that didn't surprise farmer
samuel bertron
and he had to plan for thanksgiving
turkeys back in july
we bought less turkeys because we knew
that would be
less popular they are younger birds so
they'll be a bit
smaller for less people big family
gatherings frowned upon though the finer
points of the message seem to vary
depending where you live
it's critically important that when we
get together with family
we don't endanger other family members
and so i think we'll have to use our
judgment i would prefer
canceling a lot of those in the next few
weeks to make sure that we have a nice
christmas
thanksgiving is a great time to get
together with your family and your loved
ones
we're just asking people to follow the
protocol keep it
10 people and under the bottom line
everywhere follow local rules be
safe and smart something they're doing
at the ottawa mission where the need is
greater than ever we're going to make it
awesome and wonderful and i
i did hear the prime minister's comment
but here
thanksgiving will happen it won't be a
big sit-down affair
rather thanksgiving dinner handed out
like this different
but not canceled the clients they don't
have a lot to look forward to but
one thing they look forward to it over
my 19 years is these special meals
because it's a sense of community back
on the farm they're already planning for
christmas
we got the chicks two weeks ago
so yeah we had to make a call they
bought the same number
but will grow them smaller and now like
everyone else
they wait to learn when families can
come together
again abigail beeman global news
ottawa and that is global national for
this thursday i'm donna friesen
tonight's your canada is near winnipeg
osis manitoba
northwest of winnipeg the name derives
from the cream word meaning
little muddy water we'd love to see your
canada please email it to us and thanks
for watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow take
care of yourselves
[Music]
bye-bye